one of Molly's most popular rap artists
minimal is not directly involved in
politics but his songs contain strong
political messages
he says he's disappointed with most of
the country's 24 presidential candidates
you can't do new things when it's
business as usual if you really want
change you must change the system if you
fail to do that you're just replacing
one old man with another memos point is
self-evident the field of candidates is
aiming to unseat incumbent President
Ibrahim bubucaca analysts say the 73
year-old frontrunner hasn't lived up to
expectations please don't I'm crazy of
80 Malians elected this president in
2013 for a number of key issues
re-establishing peace in the country and
recovering the north which had been
overrun by Islamists and rebels campaign
was also about instituting transparency
in government but assessing his time in
office we can see that none of these
actions have been a priority for our
current president besides the desire to
elect a leader with fresh ideas many
point to molly's need for someone who
can deal with the faltering economy like
chef Modi Bojana former prime minister
Moussa Mara abandoned his own campaign
to support Modi bachata a trained
astrophysicist he understands modern
technology better than anyone he's
highly competent in the area of science
but at the same time he's firmly rooted
in the culture both locally and
nationally but all the candidates have
to overcome the same challenge they'll
have to convince a highly skeptical
electorate of their commitment to
address people's basic needs
de novo present Kucera Ujamaa sigourney
once a new president is elected he must
urgently take care of the people and our
markets especially food staples he has
to make sure that we can afford to feed
our families the public's wish list also
includes jobs in education and most of
all an end to the violence that's been
plaguing this land for six long years
rapper mil mo hopes Sunday's election
marks a turning point from Mali I'm
launching a clear appeal to all Malians
to go out and collect their voter cards
vote for the candidate of their choice
and not allow themselves to be
influenced manipulated or corrupted and
more than anything they should not be
provoked into violence that's it let's
have peaceful elections
[Music]
[Music]